guys welcome to
episode episode 10 of opengl i want to
talk a little bit about
isometric projection so where we left
off here
we basically were running this little uh
game and of course we got our guys same
thing from last time
and we're sort of locked to this uh
whatever
this view now our camera here is at all
zeros
and it's looking down the z axis so it's
looking down the negative axis
so if you want to get your 2d
stuff into isometric projection so that
it's basically
turning into 3d except without the
perspective correction
you can use these same settings and the
only thing you want to do differently
is you want to set your view matrix
with a look at now what look at does at
least this one from glm
is it takes your eye position this is
where your eye is your camera is
and a target to look at and then
also it wants to know the world up and
with this
it calculates a view matrix to uh
basically put us in a position and look
somewhere so this is essentially the
camera
location so for example if we apply
this 100 which this is the same as 100
100 100
that's going to bring us okay yeah this
100 here is going to bring us way
towards the camera
this one right here is going to bring us
up
100 units and this one right here is
going to take us to the right 100 units
let's actually go to the left 100 units
here
oops so let's do the negative on the x
and the target is where we want to look
we want to look right at the center so
we're going to look at 0
0. however if i see where i kind of
place my
objects all of them are negative 1
on the z so they're back just a bit
if we're doing this we can actually put
them at 0 or we could say maybe our
target's just right at that center zero
zero
negative one that's right kind of in the
center
of where we're placing all these objects
and
up is just the gravity up that's our y
direction so
that's all we place there and that is
the whole function right there
so now after putting in this function
and setting that view matrix
let's see what it looks like we're
essentially going into an isometric
projection here
and you can see here it is it's the same
game everything plays the same
but now we are in this
view and this check mark is also an
isometric so it looks really weird
so yeah obviously for this particular
game it looks really weird
because it's not built to be an
isometric projection
and also you notice that i can go off
the screen right here
and that's because this is actually
clipped through
now most of these these are like
hundreds 200 wide
so there's some part of this that is
actually going through the camera
because this is like a tilted scene
and we're up at one of the top sides so
we would actually need to pull back
further and just get keep getting
further away
if we want to try to stay away from that
because
yeah these objects are pretty large
they're
scaled by 100 so like 200 wide we would
just have to keep pulling back if we
don't want to
clip in through the screen so that's the
thing you got to be aware of too
so as you can see as we pull back
further we're no longer clipping up here
now it's easier to see if there's more
going on but this is a very simplistic
view
so from this if you start placing 3d
models or boxes in here
you're going to start getting what they
call the isometric look and we'll talk a
little bit more about that
here in one second now first of all it's
pretty obvious what
isometric is i know you guys can look it
up and if you're already interested in
graphics it's
you probably already know generally what
it is it's generally
it means you're looking like in 3d but
there's no
correction to say that it's like a human
eye or an animal eye
it's just a lore it's just a literal
interpretation
of the world so you get very boxy
results as we can see
some let's just look at some images here
so here we go so if we drew this exact
thing we'd get this result and as you
can see there's no bending it doesn't
look like you can't
you can't tell how far away it is or
anything like that
so going in this sort of view that i've
demonstrated
is great for certain like strategy games
or games with grids
or games where you're not in general
uh trying to view the world from like a
proper
character 3d perspective but instead you
might need a more tactical view so this
is often something that people will use
when they're designing layouts for
things like buildings and they need to
know proper space because this
preserves the space things further away
do not get smaller
so layering does matter i you do need to
know how far things away
are because of the way they layer but
it's all very literal so
let's take a just a quick look at some
games that use this
alright let's take a look here now
there's a bunch of course uh some of
these are played
some of them i may not have now my one
of my favorite games ever
is uh xcom oh here's uh old sim city
of course simcity here we'll use
isometric some isometric tiling there
that way
yeah you obviously want all the
buildings to remain the same
scroll around the screen now maybe i can
show some examples of some techniques to
like
use mouse to drag around the screen but
we're going to need a more
robust example to do that so here's some
other games there's
just little isometric demos there's a
mario battle scene
or you can see it's an isometric so a
lot of little tactic games
and rpgs will often use this uh just to
kind of show the scale of something and
let you do all your tactics and know how
far you are away and all that stuff
as well i just make sure coffee shop so
there's a lot of really cool things
you can do with this you can stick to
this for for games and stuff too it's uh
pretty cool another reason i wanted to
go ahead and show this ice or metric is
because
we are jumping into 3d and i think it's
due time
we've kind of been messing around
showing off little things how to do
things
but i also want to get into texturing
and texturing is a big topic
so yeah i think the next thing we're
going to do
next episode we're going to talk a
little bit about texturing and then
we're going to start
turning things into 3d but i just wanted
to show you
how to do that isometric it's pretty
straightforward i'll upload the code
i did move a few things around i might
move a few others
but mainly i put the setup into the side
to the 2d game which i've renamed side
scroller
and when you set this view matrix here
to look at
that's all it takes you just need to
move your camera and the way we're going
to move our camera
is basically with this function now if
you're curious about how the math works
on this
look at you can dig into it you can go
straight into glm's code and see exactly
what they do
or you can look it up on any math site
it's it's pretty commonly well known so
i'm not going to dig into it because
ultimately
you don't necessarily need to know
unless you're rewriting this on your own
using these functions and understanding
how the eye
the center which is where you're looking
at for the
point to point your eye at and the up is
really all you need to know
and to set that as your view matrix
that's
if you're doing just game development
and
you don't care about the intricacies of
all the math and understanding every
little detail you don't really need to
know but if you are
a mathematician yeah you want to go
understand this function
so that's just my take on the whole
thing uh
it's programming takes a lot of time so
this is the end now
quick little quick little blurb about
that
because i was talking to a friend and
i think i've settled upon a game
design idea so a little channel
announcement here
um i might be a little more scarce for a
little while i'm going to try to produce
a demo of this game
within a couple weeks to a month so i'm
probably only going to do a couple
i don't know i'm not really sure what's
going to happen maybe as i dive into
code more
i'll i'll get to making videos more but
i think i'm going to have to spend a
little less time on videos because
making these actually takes a really
long time especially when i code up a
whole new section
so uh yeah when i do have that game out
it's kind of like
all private right now so i don't want to
start just saying stuff
when i do have a proper demo out i will
definitely announce it here and maybe on
my other channel too
so all right well i'll see you in the
next one and we're we're going to start
talking all about textures
how to texture these things so if you
guys want to make a cool 2d game and
just want to have sprites and textures
on it
we're going to get into that a little
bit and
uh yeah i guess that's it special thanks
to all the patrons i appreciate you guys
this month uh you guys have been amazing
you've helped me stay motivated a ton
keep making these and also join the
discord if you're coder if you have
stuff to share or just want to chat
before
we're on there
[Music]
you